um
[Music]
morning ladies and gentlemen we're ready
to proceed please be seated
[Music]
officer can you ask ms counteract to
come in and resume the stand please
thank you
good morning man because we had a break
we're going to re um swear you today so
if you can place your left hand on the
bible please raise your right hand my
clerk will administer the oath again do
you so in the presence of almighty god
that the testimony comes to this court
regarding this matter shall be the truth
the whole truth and nothing but the
truth i do please state your name must
spell your last name for the record
lauren shay kenrak
last name k a
n is a name c a r e k
all right can you have a seat ma'am
all right very good
council
thank you
good morning
yes
sir did you ever threaten
mary haskins
no
did you ever threaten
michael barrison
no
do you consider some of the
posts you put on social media
threats
i think
some could proceed that way yeah
so are you saying now that
you did threaten them
no that's not what i'm saying they
said i did not threaten michael mark
barrowson or mary haskins
you're asking i think could you repeat
that second question again let me
rephrase it
do you consider
the social media posts that you were
posting
threatening
to both barristone and mary haskins
i consider them if they could be
perceived as threatening
and
did there come a time when you knew that
michael barrasson
was scared
no
[Music]
so
was it your intention
to scare michael barriston
um maybe at the point
what point was that
i don't recall after being bullied and
tortured for weeks and days
uh
[Music]
um
this
cataract i'm going to show you exhibit
200c-32
and direct your attention to
item number
20
90. matt question yes
can you take a look at number item 2090
they're listed on the left by numbers
yes
[Music]
is a phone call
text message from your phone
of this phone outgoing
okay
it's hard to read this on the mouse i
guess a little bit yes i see okay
and does that refresh your recollection
as to whether or not
on july 25th
2019
that you
your boyfriend and
your father were aware that michael
barristone was scared
i'm sorry could you just give me one
second
[Music]
there's
[Music]
sorry i was just waiting for contact
here
are you okay irrespective of the context
isn't it a fact
that on that date july 25th 2019
that you
your boyfriend and your dad
were aware of the fact that michael
barrasson was scammed
it seems in this text message because it
says michael is scared
so who wrote that text message i believe
i wrote it
when you say i believe yes i wrote it
yes is there any question in your mind
that the records of your cell phone
indicate exactly what you wrote on that
day no i was just confused because i
wasn't sure if this number
was me sending the text or the other
person
sending the text that we were talking in
conversation okay so irrespective of who
said it
all three of you knew that michael
barrasson was scared on that thing i
wrote the words yes michael is scared
correct
now
on august 5th two days before the
shooting
[Music]
were you also
aware
that michael barrasson was scared
[Music]
possibly
would not perceive that as possible
let me show you exhibit
d10 may approach it yes
[Music]
i'm going to show you this exhibit
and refer you to
item number 9 910 from your phone
and ask you to read that to yourself
there
yeah your fans aren't hearing
what date was this
sorry august
fifth two days before the shooting
that's what i thought okay yes
um so i should i read what i wrote no
asking you were you aware
that michael barristone was scared it
seems that it can be perceived that way
although again given the context
i guess i'll just say i'll leave it at
yes i give the university that way
okay
when you say perceived
is there any doubt in your mind
that on the day reflected on this
document
you indicated
that you were aware that michael
barrasson
was
scared
yes
in this message it seems to say
he
can i can i read this just so i love you
okay no i'm asking you a specific
question if i'm not sure okay was
michael barriston scared
two days before hold on that's that's
not the question all right
no it's it's what she said her
perception she can't testify about the
defendant's state of mind only her
perceptions
rephrase your request it's withdrawn
yes your perception
of michael barristone two days before
the shooting
was that he was scared correct
sure yes
on the day before the shooting
was it your perception
that
michael barrasson
was deathly afraid
of your father
i'm sorry can you repeat the question
again
on august 6 yes
was it your perception
based on your observations of michael
barrisson
that he was deathly
afraid of your father
i would not say that he was deathly
afraid but i do think he was afraid of
my father
so if it's written
somewhere it's an exaggeration
if i can approach i show you
exhibit 200c-47
and ask you to
look at
item number 512.
yes that's exactly what i thought i
probably wrote
was your perception
the day before the shooting of michael
barrisson
that he was deathly
afraid of your father
was it my perception yes
it was my perception that michael was
afraid of my father again
i don't know if this is another example
can i read
no ma'am just just answer the questions
that's asked if there's any follow-up
needed the state can follow up with
questions so just answer the the
council's questions okay yes it was my
perception
at this time that he was afraid of my
father when you say afraid
we agree with me that there are very
varying degrees of
fear correct okay
and and can you tell the jury how you
described your perception
of michael barrisson's fear
of your father
it was described the way that it was
just red
can you he was definitely afraid that's
what was written
[Music]
now
yesterday
the prosecutor
introduced a photograph of your
your dog do you recall that i didn't
and it was a picture
uh
taken
probably
many feet away
with with your dog
just sitting there correct
correct
[Music]
oh these are ours
[Music]
defense exhibit 800
d1
okay and ask you if this is a
another picture of your door
yes it is
[Music]
how about
800 d2
oh she's yawning yes that is also my dog
you described that as a yuan
um
in that photograph and i'm referring to
800 d2
that is eons that's exactly what that is
that's something that you you posted
correct yes i posted this now
what type of dog is that
um a dachshund which is like the winnie
dog kind of thing
a dachshund and uh
minnie rottweiler she's basically a mutt
um but those are the things that the
aspca
said that she was when we rescued her
well did you ever put on social media
that she was a
doberman
mix
maybe somebody might have asked us and
he said yes possible
did you describe her as a guard dog
yes
the nighttime army
i'm sorry mr blinkist is
can i see you at the bench please
yes
during this incident
that dog
was outside at some point correct
correct
and will you agree with me
that he attacked
michael barrasso
yes
he was biting him his teeth were
grabbing his body correct
yes her teeth were
nipping at him and biting at him correct
did you see that dog
biting at his groin
area next to his genitals no i do not
see that
where did you see this dog
biting michael baraso
i mostly saw her biting him
and robert in i guess just
random places
while barking
i i was really losing a lot of blood so
i
it's not clear as to where exactly she
was you know
nipping around
sorry
well will you agree with me that
when you were talking to the prosecutor
about what exactly happened on this day
that you neglected to mention
that your dog was biting michael
barrasso
i don't know
to mention it it didn't
wasn't at the forefront of my mind and i
wasn't asked
so i didn't answer
so you'll agree with me
that contained in your
detailed statement of the event which
you've reviewed yes that nowhere did you
mention
that your dog attacked michael barrison
i i don't know exactly
i'm sorry if you just repeat that
question one more time it's a little
confusing
you've reviewed your
transcript of your
interview with the prosecutor's office
correct
um
i i'm not sure if i review the
transcript i watched a video
and will you agree with me yes that
throughout that entire video
when you were questioned with regards to
this specific instance
nowhere in that video
did you mention that your dog attacked
michael barista i don't remember it was
right after i got out of the hospital
if it's not in there it was
probably not the first thing in my mind
to say about what happened
when you got shot by the shooter who
shot you
mentioning a dog
barking was probably not the first thing
or
not
um nipping was probably not the first
four thing in my mind
when you say nifty what do you mean by
that
i mean nipping like just like
you know barking just
nipping
at
the people
that were involved in
what was going on at that moment which
was
not me at that very moment
uh
i'm going to object to the spoil being
shown to the witness
you're gonna have her comment on a photo
of an injury
and her characterization of it
not qualified to do that mr malinkas
[Music]
so miss cataract
based on your recollection of the event
it's your
testimony
that
your observations of your dog
were that he was
just nipping
at michael barrison yes
was he nipping hard enough to break the
skin based on what you saw i have no
idea they're all wearing clothing
so i don't i have no idea
now
on the sixth
did that dog attack
dr cox
i believe again did my rule on this
already mr balance
objection sustained move on mr blankas
now yesterday you talked about a uh a
plan
that you had with regards to michael
barrasso
was part of your plan
to destroy michael barrasso was to
contact dyson or dcpp
no at least
no no actually
did you
in fact contact dice
i impacted not contact like this
on july 10
2019
did you search on your phone
for the dices hotline
i don't recall
i don't believe snowball
[Music]
on july 31st
do you recall searching
dice's
anonymous hotline
i do not recall but it's possible
i'm going to show you what has been
marked
defense exhibit 200 b1
and i'm going to refer you to item
number 83.
[Music]
what's that number council 83 judge
thank you it's july 31st
this is looks like a search or something
not not a phone call
i asked you specifically
did you search
for dice's anonymous hotline on that day
and i didn't recall now you've shown me
now i recall
[Music]
did you also search
for dice's hotline on july 10th
possibly
i'm showing you the same exhibit i'm
referring you to item number 206
and ask you
if that refreshes your recollection
as to whether or not you were searching
for differences hotline on that day
to ten
different day
yes
so when you say possibly
you did in fact
search
for dice's number
on those two occasions correct
it looks that way yes
when you say it looks that way is there
any doubt in your mind
based on those records that i just
showed you that you did in fact do that
there is doubt in my mind but
again it is on my record so
it was searched
from my phone
what is the doubt in your mind can we
talk about that for a second
sure
would you where would you like me
let him ask a question what is the doubt
in your mind after looking at those
records
that you in fact were searching for
differences anonymous hotline
the doubt in my mind is this
earlier that year
justin hardin michael's assistant
trainer
had stolen my phone at a restaurant and
we caught him like we called it and we
found him in his vehicle
breaking into my phone and going through
it just like a month or two before
around
so well yes it's possible that i was
just simply searching
for a hotline number or just start
making inquiries online
it's also possible that justin hardin
who does possess
phone technological skills that i do not
after having stolen my phone and broken
into it
just right before this
may have been able to do things in my
phone that i did not
and
so that's the only reason i'm saying
this
i don't know whether that's true
it could have definitely been me
but there was always
a doubt in my mind regards to things
that were done after that phone was
stolen two
separate occasions
seems that way yes
now
on the sixth
you're aware of the fact that the town's
people came
to this facility correct
can you
inform the jury how
that came about sure
so
at this point
no one is speaking
um michael's girlfriend at the time
and and michael but mostly the
girlfriend
a couple together had told
the staff members apparently
not to respond to any of our messages
no if we had a question about feed
don't respond nothing
we learned
that
i think we were doing night check
that there was a
a dryer not a washing machine but a
dryer clothing dryer that was plugged in
in the on position
and would not turn off and as a horse
owner that is your biggest fear a barn
fire that is all you think about
we texted or i
i texted one of michael's main staff
members
this is cassandra
we overheard you telling ruth that the
dryer is not turning off
and she's sleeping
she didn't hear you
and that will definitely cause a fire
could you please just confirm
that
you've turned it off or it's unplugged
anything just so i can go to sleep for
the night basically
she did not answer me
i think i texted her again
saying cassandra please
i'm
really really worried about this the
dryer's on it cannot be in the on
position
well plugged in
just going and going in all night long
in
the stable area
where all my horses are
again she ignores me i believe i might
have texted michael also
and if i did it was certainly ignored
and
i think the following day or the
maybe the day prior whenever this
incident happened and there was zero
response
nobody was letting us know
just yes it's fine it's off
you're good to go
it was my decision to let the fire
marshal know there were fire hazards
going on they were not answering us
and
we needed to take it to
a different level and bring it to the
attention of the fire marshal because
that's how scary it was
for us
at this time at that time
isn't it a fact
that part of your plan to destroy
michael barrasso
was to get him kicked out of the stable
area
and make him homeless
maybe
maybe
yes maybe
so
would you agree with me that it's a
little bit more than maybe a washer or a
dryer causing an issue than what you
just testified to
no because we had no idea that that
would be a result of calling a fire
marshal and built our building in centre
so i would not say it was a plan to get
him evicted from at least not my plan
to get him evicted from
the barn we simply called biomartial
and building sector
i have no idea what the building
inspector
thing was exactly
that wasn't my
forte but the fire marshall part of it
was
this
is this a
one and a half page letter
that you wrote
to the building
department and fire marshall
yes i i wrote this this is my
handwriting correct
so
first of all there was a lot more than a
call correct
there is
this blood this letter
not even sure if there's a call actually
but there was we notified them i should
have used that word okay so i apologize
they were notified when you just
testified that you called them that was
incorrect
i i misspoke i'm not sure if we actually
called or
i should have been said
notified
call is probably the wrong choice of
word
when you say notify
did you send the town a detailed letter
with regards to
various
issues
at both the house and the stable
yes
did you inform them that
the condition
was dangerous and possibly illegal
sorry
did you just repeat the question i
wasn't sure if you said which area we're
referring to which we're referring
would you agree with me that this letter
sets forth
numerous things that you alleged create
a dangerous situation in both
the house
and the stable area that would be a
correct statement yeah and part of this
has to do with the
construction that is currently going on
correct
um correct
and
isn't it the fact that your boyfriend
was doing a lot of the work
pretty much all of it but most of the
yes correct
you basically indicated to them that
it's a very dangerous and illegal
situation correct
um yes that was written
i was just noticing um it was robert
goodwin that actually
wrote it but everything is not important
yes
when you say robert goodwin actually
wrote it
doesn't your signature your signature
appear on it right below his as a
witness
to this
letter yes
and who drafted this letter you were
robert um we judged it together
um was supposed to be typed
so i wasn't supposed to be written like
this but
it was dragged about both of us
did you have robert personally go down
to the town
and talk to these people i didn't have
robert do anything i simply
wrote a letter
that we both composed together
that
i think expressed our concerns over
several things
and
by doing that
you knew that quite possibly
barista would be kicked out of the
stables correct
incorrect we did not know that was going
to be a result of anything we just
wanted them to check
things out and my
my main concern
was again the fire hazard
which is the first paragraph
so on on the sixth the day before the
shooting
the town people actually came correct
i believe so i think i believe that was
date what i'm
saying well you you were on the property
that day correct yes i just don't
remember it was that day or the day
before
but they were there
and
when those people came
did rob goodwin
show them around
and point out
the hazardous conditions
if he did i wasn't with him so he did i
don't know
after the police
strikedown after the town officials
came
through both the farmhouse and the
stable area
they basically put notices on the door
indicating that everyone had to vacate
correct
of this stable area only stable and the
farm house where you and robert were
living
i'm sorry
i'm sorry did that seem like two
separate questions okay just break it
down mr malinka one at a time
with regards to the
structure that you and robert goodwin
were living in
did the town place a notice
on the building
indicating that it was the hazardous
condition
and that
you could not occupy the structure
yes
okay i'm going to show you d 822
and ask you was these are the notices
that were posted on the
farmhouse
yes
and
did you read these notices i did
and
it indicates that if you don't
leave the premises it subjects the owner
of the building to a 5 000
fine per day correct
that's not what i recall reading no what
do you recall reading regarding these
notices i recall
reading
that in our specific section of the
house
there were
um
smoke detectors that were for some
reason not working that i guess me
the building inspector seemed to think
that
mr barristone had ripped out the
hardwiring
for some reason
and we read those
and then they gave us the opportunity to
fix them
and re-enter the property that's what i
read
you read that on these i mean i read
those violations yes okay and those
violations say
if you remain on the premises
the owner is subject to a five thousand
dollar fine do you recall reading that
no i just got to the violation
i don't remember reading the entire
thing at all just violence
it's your testimony that
you had communications with the town
correct
correct
and
you remained on
the premises with your boyfriend robert
goodwin correct
and even though you remained on the
premises
you continued to display
the notices
that were placed on
all the doors
correct
i honestly don't remember that that
picture
looks like maybe it was after
when you say you don't remember
i don't remember do you re you've seen
photographs that the prosecutor has
shown you regarding this incident
correct
and and those photographs includes
pictures of the door where the bullet
hole went through correct correct
and
if i show you this photo again 822
does that look like the door
with the shattered glass on it
yes it does
yes it does would you agree with me that
if
the glass was shattered
i'm going to object to this lining
yeah
move on
now
on august 5th
the day
you sent that letter to the town
did you receive the letter from michael
barrissone's lawyer
basically
telling you to get out
basically saying that yes
and
did that make you angry
yeah
and
on the sixth
the day
the town came and
michael barrasson out of the stable were
you served with an infection complaint
an eviction complaint we were never
served with a court eviction papers of
any kind
aside from the lawyer
are you 100
percent
sure
of that answer
i i would say yes
i didn't see anything
nothing was on our door
saying you were being evicted
i was not served with anything
so
yes that would be my answer
[Music]
now on the sixth and the seventh
you were still
posting negative things about michael
barriston
correct
correct
now
on the seventh
strike back
prior to the
seventh
on august
4th
were you angry at michael barrison
yes
were you searching for exploding bullets
on your phone
objection
let me see it cyborg
now on the seventh
was there an
issue with your boyfriend and the
blacksmith
the morning of the shooting
there was an issue with the blood
without a furrier i do not remember what
morning or day it was though
i'm referring to the judgment here say
objection
was she present
is this something she knows from her own
personal observations you have to
establish a foundation counsel
otherwise it's hearsay
yes she knows about it but from what
source
if it's from her boyfriend telling her
that's hearsay
if she was present and observed it she'd
be able to testify based on her own
perceptions and recollection
on the morning of the shooting
were you angry at michael
barriston so that last question is
withdrawn right yes all right the record
will reflect that
on the morning of the shooting were you
angry at michael barrison
yes
and did you want
that
bastard
finish
yes
you wanted
that bastard
fitness author has asked an answer mr
blancas one time is enough for the
jurors
now
you were never afraid of michael
barrasson correct
was that do you repeat that question you
were never afraid of michael barrasso
correct
not correct
um
do you recall an occasion in july where
he came to talk to you
and there was an altercation between you
and him
probably there are a few so
yes
do you remember the time he drove down
in his truck
similar to what he did on this day
to come and talk to you about something
yes
do you recall in that instance
getting into a semi rage and backing him
up all the way to his truck which was
parked in front of his porch do you
recall doing that to him
no
do you recall him trying to open his
door pleading to leave but you literally
stood in his door
so he could not drive away do you recall
doing that to him on that day no i did
not recall doing that to him do you
recall when he tried to open his truck
door
hold on
let me see it's sidebar
but the objections overruled
with the court's direction mr blankish
you can't continue
with regards to this incident referred
to on july 12
2019
when michael barrisson
okay to talk to you
at some point he was trying to run away
correct
i don't recall
at some
point he tried to open up his truck door
to get away from you
and you slammed it shut
and wouldn't allow him to leave correct
i don't recall he came there to confront
me in my face and i really
don't recall what happened after that i
was i was in fear
do you you were in fear on this day yes
do you recall him
pleading with you
to leave
i do not recall that no and you
literally standing in his door
so he could not drive away i don't
recall that okay i'm to show you d200c35
[Music]
which i'm saying which number was it
there's a whole bunch of numbers let's
go first with
four four eight nine at the top
okay
so the whole thing no read this one
we'll go one by one
4489 this is a text message correct yes
from your phone okay
yes
and does it refresh your recollection on
this day
that he came to my porch got in my face
and tried to berate me
but all i
it did was make me throw down my phone
and stand in his face
until my semi rage
had backed him all the way
to his truck
which was parked in front of his porch
you recall saying those exact words
um
i can see that i wrote them so now i
recall sending this message to my
boyfriend yes
your boyfriend and your dad correct
um i don't
see
if there's an expert
yes they're both on that same thread
correct
and
do you recall on that day and i'll refer
you to 4493
judge i believe at sidebar we talked
about this was going to be used for
impeachment when she said that she
wasn't scared of him not for substantive
evidence so i think the point has been
made there i don't know that it's
necessary to go through every text
message
that was the day
your representation mr belinkus
would you agree with me that on this day
you're referring to
you were not afraid of michael barrasso
no i was afraid
i just don't think anybody was there
and
i
if that's what i texted it was either
just what i texted my boyfriend and
father
or
those actions happened in that sequence
but i remember feeling afraid
that he came to the house
came at me
when no one else was there
and
if my action was to get up
and be back in his space hoping maybe
that would
get him to go away
that was my action
it wasn't the first time he had done it
all right let's go to the uh the day of
the incident
i'm gonna give you a copy of your
transcript
that's not good
i'm going to give you a copy of your
transcript because i'm going to try to
say some
steps
[Music]
on the day of the shooting
do you recall michael barrasson
arising
yes
and
is it your
testimony
that you had no idea
why he was coming down
to the farmhouse correct that is my
testimony
how is he driving
he was driving he was driving down a
driveway
kind of the way he always drives like a
little
crooked all over the place
did you describe his driving to the
prosecutor as uh
like a crazy person
kind of the way he always drives so
probably
probably did say that can you please
look at your transcript page five check
lines six and seven
and tell me whether or not that
refreshes your recollection as to
whether you told the process i think she
just did that mr balancas
she just acknowledged that
not definitively judge yes she did
all right i'll move on
now how did he park
um
[Music]
meaning like
what position or in
what what were your observations of him
parking i
don't recall exactly because
i wasn't paying attention to all that i
saw him pull in the driveway
and then
i went to go get up upstairs
to get my boyfriend
so i'm not sure if i actually
witnessed him parking
or not i don't actually don't think i
did
i i don't i really don't remember hers i
definitely just remember
him driving into the driveway
all right
mr blinkist we need to take a break for
a minute we're having some
diff well
we're not taking a morning break um
don't get ahead of ourselves here we're
just having an issue with the recording
equipment
so
oh
everything is being recorded and it was
just a very small
um break where there was an issue with
it but it's
been resolved now so go ahead mr blancas
miss cataract
yes
when you saw
michael barrasso
his truck
down the driveway
and pulling into
the parking area in the back of the
house
[Music]
were you concerned
yes
did you think something was wrong
yes
what did you think was wrong
i didn't know but i knew something was
wrong since
it had not been a good week
tensions were high
and now all of a sudden
he's
driven
all the way to our apartment for some
unknown reason
i'm out there by myself on the porch
i did not feel comfortable or safe
to the point that i had to run upstairs
and make sure my boyfriend would come
down with me
just for safety reasons
yeah
did you think
that something was wrong because of all
the things you and your boyfriend were
doing to him
um
it could have added to it
and based on what you knew about what
you were doing
you were concerned correct
i was like can you repeat that question
when you see michael barriston
he parks his vehicle you were outside
correct
i was outside when you drove in the
driveway correct and at that point you
go inside to get your boyfriend rob
correct yes
and when you found rob
he was on the telephone correct with
your attorney correct
now
do you know when rob called your civil
attorney
no i do not
what did you say to rob
i said rob michael's outside i have no
idea why he's here
but
he's here i don't know why
we hadn't been speaking for days we
wouldn't answer our texts even about a
fire hazard and he's now in our driveway
temper problem
that we've seen over the course of the
time we were there
so that's what happened okay so
you stay inside and rob goes outside to
talk to michael barrasso correct
incorrect okay what happened
i went to get rob
he came outside
to the porch
we were both on the porch for a moment
robert
i don't remember if he exactly entirely
entirely
left the porch or he was just
like sort of to the left of me
um like on the stairs or near it i don't
remember exactly
um
i can continue so
michael
then says to robert
how do we fix things like i'm sorry i
don't want a war
how do we make everything better
to which robert replied
michael
you want to do that we have lawyers
involved
you have a lawyer we have a lawyer let
them talk
and handle it this way
he then came back to the porch was
michael calm at that point completely
gone
uh would you describe him as sorrowful
yes
now
have you looked at your boyfriend's
transcript of his testimony
i have not
have you talked to your boyfriend
about this incident
yes
did you talk to him last night about
this incident
probably but the shooting itself
we always talk about that
it's a lifelong life
changing incident to have someone try to
murder you so yes
probably
now
at that point after that conversation
with
michael barisson and your boyfriend
isn't it the fact that your boyfriend
walked inside the house
well i'm sorry can you repeat that make
sure i'm exactly right okay
please listen carefully yes they will
isn't it a fact
that after your boyfriend had that
conversation with michael barrison
he walked
back into the house
not directly no
when did he walk back into the house
um
after the police was there were there
and
i guess separated
um barristone and
my boyfriend
he opened the door
to
put the dog into the house
that's what that's when he really laughs
after
your boyfriend is done talking to
michael barissell
he you
come out correct
i then come off the porch and he's been
on the porch
and how would you describe your demeanor
at that point
interested
well do you recall telling the
prosecutor that you walked out thinking
i'm like miss badass or something
your exact words to them no i don't
recall that do you have the date of that
by any chance
it's the transcript in front of you
september 5th
page 6
lines 5 and 6. was it
page six page six
line six
seven and five
again this is september 5th right so
i'm just trying to um
page six line six
so oh my god i wish i could change that
just read it to yourself man
just read it to yourself to refresh your
recollection
yes
did you come out
like miss badass
yes or no
no
did you tell the prosecutor
that you came out
like miss badass i tell them that i walk
out thinking
that
i'm like miss badass or something
for having
even
what i would consider now
the courage to even approach him
at all
who is miss badass
as a
character
i don't know
um at that point
were you like
sick
of this
yeah so i'm still saying you're
sick i was sick of everything that had
been gone going on that week
so again i was interested as i said
before
in what michael had to say
now
what do you recall michael saying to you
he said nothing to me
i spoke first
once i had seen or thought that there
was no danger
having seen robert to speak to him
and come back to the porch
unscathed
i then felt it was safe i could
have a conversation with this man
and did you speak loudly enough
where your boyfriend rob would hear what
you said
probably i think so i can't
know what he heard that i said or not
okay what did you say to michael
something along i don't know the exact
words
something long lines of
okay michael
how do you plan to fix this and how are
we going to settle rob's
i was about to say the word bill
but i don't think that ever came out of
my mouth
because
or it was like mid-word
right then
i said media sent less than a sentence
and
right then it was done out of his pocket
boom
boom
period
he runs around the table
i'm sorry excuse me i'm just caught up
boom
boom then
he raises his hand up to a robber
standing on the porch
shoots at him
in the trajectory
being the head
and i then do not see robert anymore but
i see michael
run around me and up the stairs
straight to where rob was no longer
and that is what i saw at that at that
time
is it your sworn testimony
that you
saw the actual gun before
you heard the
discharge
did you see the gun yes or no before
it discharged it
yes it did
now
you indicated yesterday that
after getting shot
in your mind
you just ran around in a circle in your
mind correct you recall saying that
yesterday
i don't remember what i recall
yesterday i remember we discussed
um
that i remember
i didn't know really where i was
disoriented
i know i ran around in an actual circle
and when you mean an actual circle
that's different than what you testified
that's not no no not mr bolenkas don't
characterize a testimony it's the jury's
recollection that counts here not yours
did you run around in a physical
circle
yes in physical circle
and
did you run around in a circle in your
mind
probably many circles in my mind
where did you go when you were running
around
in a uh
i don't know anything
but demonstrate you'd like yep please
can i take my shoes off
yes go ahead
so michael
is standing here
shoots me
and i then see him
raise his hand
shoot at robert's head
i look at my chest
and
where do you go what do you do
the circle ever around one goes
like
this
okay in that area okay perfect
sorry about that
that was embarrassing
[Music]
[Music]
do you recall telling the morris county
prosecutor in your official statement
that i took two in the
chest and i just
see blood like everywhere and
as i ran
and
this is the point where it gets a little
shady because i don't know where the
hell i went
do you recall saying that to the
prosecutor's office yes
did you show them that
little uh movement that you demonstrated
in the courtroom i did not show them
because i was referring to i didn't know
where i went meaning in my head
i know where i read the area
where i actually
moved around
do you recall telling the morris county
prosecutor's office
that i went somewhere i ran i think i
went inside
no i do like yell to rob
to recall telling the prosecutor that
about your running
i do he i did go inside to call to rob
to bring you upstairs you're saying
to the prosecutor you ran inside the
house to call rob after you were shot
didn't you say that if i did i don't
recall again
it was a few days after being released
from the hospital i was on ton of
payments i mean i didn't understood half
the questions they were asking me i
thought okay so let's turn to page six
sure
and
before i ask you a question
when you say you just got out of the
hospital yes
and we're on pain medications
you just recently
were shown your actual video
of this
interview
and you had an opportunity to see
exactly what you said
did you tell the prosecutor that there
were there were
grave issues with regards to what i
don't think she said they were grave
issues
i'll rephrase the question please did
you tell the prosecutor that you you
didn't run in the house after being shot
like you said in the official statement
i'm sorry they didn't run out so if
you'd repeat that list i couldn't
let's let's move on go to page six
there
line 21
yes do you have that i do do you recall
saying
because i don't know where the hell i
went
and this is after the shooting yes you
recall saying that
today okay and if you go down to line 24
do you recall saying i went somewhere i
ran
i think i went inside to yell to rob
do you recall saying that to the
prosecutor i don't recall it but i see
that i said it yes i don't know what it
means do you recall
after the shooting
running into the house
yelling for your boyfriend
no
you recall telling the prosecutor that
the reason why you ran to yell to rob is
because you didn't want him to come out
do you recall telling them that i'm
sorry could you just give me one second
you're speaking very goodly okay i was
going to be able to make sure yeah and
again if i'm not reading the exact words
yes bring that to my attention i
absolutely will
okay
i'm sorry i was just uh reading this for
context
what would your exact question again
did you tell the prosecutor that the
reason you ran inside the house
and yelled to rob
was
for because you didn't want him to come
out outside
where
things were going on i did say that at
that point
no i didn't know he's talking about him
did you recall
what you yelled to him
don't come out
no i did not yell that
did you tell the prosecutor when you
gave your official statement that you
yelled
to rob don't come outside
i don't actually recall that at all
if you look on page seven the first line
does that refresh your recollection of
you telling the morris county prosecutor
it refreshes words that i was saying yes
okay did you also tell the prosecutor
that
at that point
rob was not putting two and two together
that you had been shot
yes
so
will you
agree with me that when you first talk
to the prosecutor
rob
judge i'm going to object on speculation
grounds
i mean i understand why the detectives
ask her these questions but it doesn't
make it admissible evidence he's asking
her what did rob goodwin know
yeah i'm not sure i understand the
question
i mean the the the words speak for
themselves
did you tell the prosecutor
that rob heard gunshots
same objection judge
yeah i mean where would she get that
information
other than from her boyfriend making it
hearsay
sustained
at some point in time
rob
jumps on michael barisson correct
correct
were you outside i was
did you see uh rob uh choking michael
barrasso
i saw um
he had his arm
behind his back and
he had him in some kind of
like a headlock
to restrain him from being able to get
the gun again
when you say
a headlock would you describe your
observations of him putting him in a
show called
maybe
i don't know like exact terms these
things
okay when you say you don't know exact
terms
on the day of your official statement on
page eight
line six did you describe it as a
chokehold probably
can you look at it and tell me
yes or no i mean yeah i'm sure i said it
line six page eight line six
yes
do you like no
problem um
uh
[Music]
in life a chokehold
so yes i
wrote in like a joke
and your uh
your boyfriend is an ex-marine correct
now
at this point
did you
start attacking michael barrison
at which point i'm sorry
let me back up a little bit yes
thank you
when you're talking to michael barrasso
and
you're saying he's firing the shots at
you
you were on the phone
with your civil lawyer correct
well i mean i'm sorry i i
i just have a question
if you do you understand the question or
no all right rephrase your question
at the time you were talking to michael
barrasso
and when you say the shots were fired
you were physically on the telephone
talking to your civil lawyer correct i
was physically holding the phone
um and talking
to michael about her song okay but your
lawyer was on the line
yes
and whose phone was that
roberts
so
can i assume when
you took two shots into the chest
you dropped the phone
[Music]
no i didn't drop the phone
i'm not that i'm sorry not that i recall
i did not remember dropping involved
what do you remember with doing
doing with that phone
i honestly forgot i had it in my hand
i totally forgot that ed david was still
on the phone
at some point in time you start beating
michael barrison with your phone correct
did you have two phones in your hand
no what did you do with the phone robert
goodwin's phone
after you were shot
i
told ed david
oh my god oh my god not asking you what
you told them
what did you specifically do with the
phone
at what point in time let's specify
after being shot
can you just read the whole question
absolutely so sorry
you're you're holding the phone yes
where you
were having a conversation with your
civil lawyer correct
right yes correct
okay you claim you got shot at that
point collect correct
correct okay
what did you do with the phone that you
were holding
after you were shot i believe i just
kept holding it
at some point in time
you pick
up your telephone correct
where was that telephone that was by the
door
that was not the door to the laundry
room
which is now like semi-open
which was from
rob jumping through the door to avoid
being hit in the head of the bullet
um so
my phone was somewhere right around
there
okay so let me stop we'll show you small
steps here so it's your testimony
that after being shot
two times in the chest
out on the patio by that
round table correct
wait i'm sorry that was confusing could
you say it one more time i'm so sorry
where were you shot
i was shot observed
i mean the location on the porch
i'm going to show you d803
[Music]
can you put a big x
does this accurately uh depict the area
where the incident occurred the area yes
what's that right there
that is a camera
a window now
can you put a big x
where
you were standing when you got shot
a little hard to do because
everything's all
i guess just do it to the best you can
okay
uh i was standing
i want you to
[Music]
try that later
[Music]
so
so the record is clear
and this mark is saying on
d803 but you can see it
you put
kind of like a star
basically right next to the metal table
and chairs correct
okay
and that's
that's where you say you were standing
when you got shot correct that is
correct
and from that round table and chairs
you
walk all the way to the
back steps after being shut
climb up the stairs
and get your phone
yes i wanted to call 9-1-1
is there any reason why you didn't use
rob's phone that you already had in your
hand well
one thing i
wasn't even thinking that i had it
when i did realize
the first thing i did i think i think
the first thing i did
was let the person i was on the phone
with no
oh my god i just been shot right i'm not
asking you that i'm asking you what you
did with the phone
okay with the phone
right so the phone that you were on
at the time
you claim you were shot
after you're shot it's your testimony
that you
walk all the way over to the stairs
climb a flight of stairs
and get your telephone correct more
crawled
yeah i wasn't exactly like running
i was just
i was losing
a lot of blood
so
yes but
i didn't even ask if i crawled or walked
or just
all right so what did you do what what
hand were you holding the phone i think
i think i'm right-handed so i would
think my right hand okay so what did you
do with that phone
i think after i told ed david what had
happened
i think i just like placed it on forever
the porch area that i was then on
and for some reason
yeah that's about to say
and
you didn't use that phone to call 9-1-1
correct
you
looked for and found your own personal
phone correct yes
and then when you found your phone
did you come back
down the stairs
to the area where
michael and your boyfriend were
struggling on the ground
when i found my phone i
i got my phone
i
tried to call 9-1-1
i couldn't
because my arms and my hands were
covered in blood that phone would not
open okay so
what was the second half of your
question how did you call 9-1-1 you're
the person
the first person on the 9-1-1 call
correct yes i then remembered oh yes
robert's phone is out here i'll use
rob's phone and call 9-1-1 which i did
too okay so
let me get the scenario correct
mr malinka's
we don't need a summation now just ask
your questions
all right
what did you do with your phone at that
point
i'm sorry which point
at the point
when you realized you couldn't call
9-1-1
and you
decided to get rock's phone
i put it back down
put it back down where wherever i picked
it up from like i just described a
moment ago
near the door
by the laundry room which was also next
to where the love seat was because it
was in the floor so
you came down the stairs with your phone
to where rob
and barriston was struggling
you tried to call 9-1-1
correct
incorrect
i went up the stairs
to get my phone
and tried to call 9-1-1 and my phone
would not open
i then put my phone back down
you put your phone back down on that
atlantis yeah yeah um no i
my memory
in my memory i remember putting it back
down right where i picked it up which
was somewhere on the actual porch
because that's where it was
put it down
um
and then you go and retrieve
the phone that you would previously
place some somewhere correct yes because
i remember that i wouldn't need to and
where was that from where was that from
we're somewhere near the vicinity of
where
um robert was restraining michael
okay and
at that point
is when you claim you called 9-1-1
correct
and
everybody's heard the 9-1-1 call
so you're on the phone
after a period of time
you hand the phone to your boyfriend
correct i think he kind of took it
at that point because i
had my phone again
and what do you mean you had your phone
i i went to go i think i
had my phone
because
did you just strike that didn't you just
indicate that you placed your phone
back on the landing yeah back in the
area
like to me
where they were having their
where rob was restraining michael
in my memory i do not remember if they
were actually like
still on the porch or just
two steps below on a landing it was it
was just
did you say yesterday they they were off
of the landing off the stairs on that
concrete patio i believe i said i wasn't
sure that it was they're two stairs okay
so we can go back over it if you look
too
um
but what i believe i said it was
anything i'm saying now
which is that i don't remember if they
were actually on
the porch flat area
or like
a step or two below
on the patio i don't remember exactly
where that was so
and again correct me if i'm wrong you
call 9-1-1
you have a discussion with them and then
rob has
his phone back correct
a 9-1-1 after i had spoken to them right
which is very brief right yes
and is it your recollection
that after rob took the phone from you
you walked up the stairs and got your
phone again
i didn't walk anywhere
um
there is a point that i went and got my
phone when when was that point well let
her finish mr belenkus
somewhere in between
after i
told
911 i'd been shot
rob was
you know you could hear him struggling
with michael
at that time
i
grabbed my phone
i was covered in blood
i crawled somewhere whether it was an
inch away or
half a foot away
to get my phone thinking the only way
that i could help the situation
is
by helping to make sure no one else gets
shot or killed that day
which is
why
i had my phone and was hitting michael
on the head with it
you're with it
how long
were you beating michael barrasson with
your phone
maybe a matter of seconds
you're sure of that pretty sure yes i
didn't have
yeah yes i'm definitely sure
to recall previously saying
that you used your seven minutes to help
rob
by keeping the six foot four mv subdued
by breaking my phone in his cheek and in
his ear
do you recall saying that
you were beating him for seven
minutes
let's not wait a second mr balance
that's not what it said
okay let's not don't characterize things
ask a question if you're reading from
something read the specific words do not
characterize it okay
did you say these exact words
i used my seven minutes
to help rob
keep the six foot four
m b
subdued
by breaking my iphone
on his cheek and in his ear
probably said that
seven minutes you claim to be beating
michael barrasso isn't that correct
can we just put that in context yes
please
oh you can do that on redirect that's
what redirect is for mr shelton
did you also tell everybody that you
were meta fact in a helicopter
yes they did
that never happened either did it um i
didn't learn that until literally two
weeks ago okay my
question is i think she answered the
question mr belenkus
what's your question
that
she wasn't medevaced in a helicopter
which is inconsistent with her stadium
her saying i just learned that is not a
direct answer i believe
ask it again
you said you were medivac
helicopter exactly yes
you weren't medivac by helicopter
correct as it turns out that is correct
and when you say you just found out two
weeks ago
that was when you went over your
statement with the prosecutor correct
the video
okay and you corrected that statement
correct
you had an opportunity to correct
what you said on that video correct
i know i'm sorry
i'll move on
[Music]
now
[Music]
did you indicate to the prosecutor
that with regards to
that point of time
when you start hitting michael barrison
with your iphone phone
that your boyfriend robert goodwin
was not even aware that you were shot
objection
calls for speculation
i'm referring to her statement but the
information she gets in the statement
it's hearsay within hearsay
sustained
now
do you recall bashing and bashing
and bashing
that guy's
freaking ear in with your phone i do
you recall that
during that time at some point michael
barrisson was unconscious
no i do not recall that can you please
look at page 10
line 13
and ask me if that refreshes your
recollection
as to whether or not during that time
[Music]
michael barrison was unconscious for a
few seconds
what line on page 10
line 13.
yes this is my perception
i know i have not
and
with regards to your hitting michael
barrasson in the head with your phone
did you stop at one point and then start
up
again um
yes very quickly
when you say very quickly what was the
time period between when you first
started to
bash your phone into his head yes
in relationship to the second time you
started doing that
pretty much the first time
i did it
you did
one like one time
and then my boyfriend
once
this is what he told me he saw
a
giant i can't say with someone else oh
i'm sorry
anyway my boyfriend realizing the damage
had
tried
moving me
or like kind of
making me
not be where they were
so that i wouldn't just i guess all over
and die
so but i didn't want to i was worried
again about the gun going off so at that
point i came back and tried to hit him
again with the bone and then i just
walked right out of everything just
any adrenaline that i may have had
just
died
[Music]
now
during this time
what did you observe your dog doing
[Music]
during which time specifically this is
where
your boyfriend is on top of michael
barracelle
and you're
hitting him in the head with your phone
same answers before
which is
i witnessed her
nipping and
yeah just pretty much nipping both of
them
like in different areas and and barking
okay
it was during the time
when your boyfriend was physically
struggling with michael barrison
and you were
hitting him in the head with your phone
yes
are you sure that
that didn't go on
before any shots were fired then what go
on
you got to clarify the beating
the torque by the jag
the door
and her
slamming her phone into his head
you